Most UXUI advice out there teaches you
the same surface level stuff. Use white
space, align your text, pick better
colors. But if you want to actually
become a great designer, the kind who
creates interfaces people love to use
and remember, you need more than that.
In this video, we'll be sharing five
advanced UXUI design tips you won't hear
in most courses or tutorials. Let's get
into it. One, personalize the experience
based on user behavior. When you're
designing a product, it's important to
remember that not all users are the
same. Some are brand new, some are
coming back after a few uses, and others
are deeply engaged. But what many
beginner designers do is show everyone
the same screen, no matter where they
are in their journey. That's a missed
opportunity. Designing experiences that
adapt to different types of users can
make your products feel smarter, more
personal, and way more useful. Let me
show you what this looks like using a
fitness app. The first screen is for a
new user. They've just signed up, so the
app keeps things really simple. It
welcomes them and encourages them to set
their weekly goals. Underneath, there
are a few trending programs and some
easy categories. It's just enough to
explore, but not overwhelming, which is
exactly what a firsttime user needs.
Next, we've got a repeat user. This
person has used the app before and is
starting to build a routine. Instead of
onboarding content, they get a clear
workout plan for the day with helpful
details like duration and calories
burned. Now, here's a super user,
someone who's fully engaged and
committed to their fitness goals. The
app experience becomes more advanced. We
start with useful stats like daily
steps, calories burned, and heart rate.
Then it moves into their workout plan
and personalized diet suggestions. At
this stage, it's not about helping them
get started. It's about helping them
optimize and stay on track. Great design
meets people where they are. Instead of
creating one generic experience for
everyone, think about how your interface
can adapt to what the user needs right
now. Small changes like personalized
messages, tailored content, or progress
tracking can make your product feel more
human, more helpful, and more valuable.
Two, design smarter search. Search is
one of the most critical features in any
product. But it's also one of the most
overlooked in design. Most designers
just drop in a search bar and move on.
But good search design isn't just about
function. It's about how it feels, how
fast it helps users get what they need,
and how much effort it saves them. Think
about what happens when a user taps into
a search bar. That's a moment of intent.
They're looking for something, but they
may not know exactly what. That's where
your design can do one of two things.
Give them a blank screen and expect them
to do all the work. Or offer helpful
suggestions that make the experience
easier, faster, and smarter. Let's look
at the first version, the standard blank
screen search. Technically, it works,
but there's no guidance. It's a dead end
unless they know exactly what they want.
Now, let's look at a smarter version of
the same screen. The search bar is still
there, ready to use, but underneath it,
the interface offers subtle, useful
suggestions. Things like recent
searches, so the user can quickly pick
up where they left off. Popular items,
which gives them a sense of what others
are finding useful. Personalized
recommendations based on their past
behavior or interest. These suggestions
don't get in the way. They quietly
support the user. And if they already
know what they want, they can ignore
them and just type. But if they're
unsure, these small hints reduce
friction and give them somewhere to
start. Three, smarter order tracking
design. Here's something a lot of
designers overlook. Post-purchase
experiences matter just as much as the
purchase itself. Think about it. When
someone places an order, they've already
made a decision. They've paid,
committed, and now they're waiting. That
moment between payment and delivery is
full of expectation and uncertainty. And
how you design for that moment says a
lot about your product. Now, let's take
a look at a very basic order screen. It
shows the order number, a plain list of
items, some courier info, and a timeline
made up of simple dates. Technically,
the information is there, but visually
there's no structure, no prioritization,
no guidance, just data dumped onto a
screen. The user has to scan, interpret,
and piece everything together
themselves. Now, compare that to this
upgraded design. From the very first
glance, this screen makes you feel like
everything is under control. It opens
with a confident message. Your order is
on the way, paired with clear delivery
details and visual icons that help
communicate the time window and address
instantly. The courier section is no
longer just a name and number. It's
human. There's a photo, a name, and
quick access buttons to call or message,
which not only adds trust, but makes the
experience feel more personal and
responsive. The items, no more long text
lists. And one of the best touches, the
order history is now a visual timeline.
Instead of scanning a block of text and
dates, users can instantly see what
stage the order is in. This isn't just a
UI upgrade. It's a completely different
experience because great design doesn't
just display information. It reduces
stress and answers questions before
they're asked. Speaking of great
designs, a lot of people ask us, "How do
I make my UI designs actually look good?
Not just functional, not just okay, but
clean, modern, and something people
actually want to use." If you're trying
to figure that out, I really recommend
checking out our UX UI design playbook.
It's packed with the exact principles,
visual tips, and layout rules that
helped thousands of new designers, and
also developers finally understand how
to design great UI designs. You'll find
real examples, prolevel shortcuts, and
simple things you can apply right away
to make your designs feel way more
polished and confident. In fact, a lot
of our students said this was the best
UI design ebook that finally helped them
to improve their UI designs. We just
crossed 17,000 downloads of the free
preview and full version, which is
honestly amazing. The price may go up
soon, but right now you can get 40% off
with the code love peak 40. So, if you
haven't grabbed your copy yet, this is
the perfect time. Links in the
description. And when you try it, I'd
love to hear how it helped your designs.
We've already seen some amazing
transformations.
[Music]
Four, category screens. Category screens
might seem simple, just a list of
options, right? but they actually play a
huge role in how users move through your
product. Let's look at three different
versions of this screen and how the
design affects the experience. The first
version is very basic, just a list of
category names and C selection links.
There's nothing wrong with it. It's
clean and minimal. But the problem is it
puts all the effort on the user. Every
line looks the same. There's no visual
rhythm, no hierarchy, and no cues that
help guide the eye. You have to read
through every label to find what you
want. Now, the second version is
something we see a lot from junior
designers. It looks more designed and
might even seem impressive at first
glance, but here's the thing. It focuses
more on appearance than on usability.
Even though there's a dark overlay to
help with some text readability, it
doesn't fully fix the contrast issue.
Some of the text is still hard to read.
On top of that, the images don't match.
One is bright, another is moody, another
feels like a magazine photo. There's no
visual consistency. It doesn't feel like
these images belong to the same product
or brand, more like a random mix of
stock photos. And because every block is
so visually busy, it takes longer for
users to understand what they're looking
at. Now, let's look at the third
version. And this is where things come
together in a much more thoughtful,
professional way. This design uses
color-coded charts, each with a soft,
solid background and a clean, isolated
image that represents the category.
Because the images are stylistically
unified and the background colors are
well balanced, the whole screen feels
cohesive and branded. There's a rhythm
to the layout that makes scanning
effortless. You can glance at the screen
and understand the options in just
seconds. Five, choose the right input
method for the moment, not just the
data. Not all number inputs are created
equal, and they shouldn't be treated the
same. Entering your weight, age,
calories, or daily steps might seem
similar on the surface, but the way
those values are entered can completely
change how smooth or frustrating the
experience feels. Let's walk through a
few real examples and break down what
works best and why. First, consider the
type of input. There are two kinds of
numeric input scenarios. onetime setup
like entering your weight when first
signing up or setting your age, height
or weight and frequent repeated entry
like locking food to track calories or
macros. These are completely different
use cases and they require completely
different UI patterns. Let's look at the
screen where the user is asked to enter
personal details like weight or height.
In these cases, scroll wheels and
sliders work beautifully. Why? Because
users aren't entering this data often.
They just want to get through the setup
quickly and these values usually fall
within a known range. And most
importantly, they are low effort. Users
don't need to type or think too much.
Now, let's compare that to logging your
food every day to track calories or
macros. This is where sliders and scroll
wheels break down. They're too slow, too
fiddly, and don't offer the kind of
control users need. If you want to log
food quantity like 350 g, I don't want
to scroll endlessly or try to drag a
slider to the perfect number. Text
fields are better here because they're
faster, more precise, and less
frustrating when used repeatedly. So,
how do you choose? Here is a simple rule
of thumb. Use sliders or scroll wheels
for casual one-time inputs where
precision isn't critical. Use text
fields, steppers, or number inputs for
frequent, precise, or repetitive tasks.
It's not about which component looks
nicer. It's about reducing friction and
matching the input method to the
context. That's all for today. We hope
you found these tips helpful. Let us
know in the comments which one was your
favorite. We'll see you on the next one.